[Musik]
was würdest du tun wenn du das passwort
sämtliche computer wlan netze und social
media account hängen könnte
könntest du dieser versuchung
widerstehen und deine macht für das gute
einsetzen oder würdest du diese machen
ist brauchen 2017 entstand durch
cyber-angriffe alleine in deutschland
einen schaden von 2 4 milliarden euro
regelmäßig enthüllen hacker private
daten wie zum beispiel nackt bilder oder
handynummern von prominenten doch es
gibt auch eine szene welche sich als
tugendhaft versteht und zb die sekte
scientology den rassistischen
ku-klux-klan oder sogar ds gehackt haben
doch wie genau funktioniert das
eigentlich und kann es jeder lernen
diese woche treffe ich mich mit einem
profi der mir in einer woche das hacken
beibringen will
dieses video wird unterstützt von der
schleyer halle war voll ist wie
funktioniert hätten heisst ja also
hacken ist ein sehr breites ich glaube
du musst dich erst mal entscheiden was
genau die recken möchte ist also überall
freies wlan zu haben das wäre natürlich
schon ein schöner gedanke
ich habe mir vorgestellt wie ein video
meinen wählern zu hacken das wäre
interessant kann mir war vorgestellten
windows pin zu hacken also bei windows
ist es eigentlich einfach etwas anderes
zu machen
es gibt die möglichkeit dass du quasi
sein windows passwort einfach umgehst
das heißt du musst das nicht mal hätten
ersetzt einfach dein passwort durch ein
neues passwort das heißt das kannst du
jetzt auch bei meinem laptop einfach
machen wenn ich dir geben wird wenn du
mit ihren laptop wirklich gibst ja dann
kann ich das machen okay also das ist
auf jeden fall realistisch dass ich -
was wird da hecken lernen das ist
absolut wlan passwort kannst ja also je
nach dem halt wie schwer es ist hacken
komplett illegal aber mit erlaubnis
dürfte ist also es ist so hecken ist
eigentlich was das kannst du mehr oder
weniger auch studieren heißt it security
oder it sicherheit gerade weil
eigentlich jede firma natürlich auch
dafür sorgen muss dass sie nicht gehackt
werden zum beispiel eine webseite dazu
zu bringen das zu tun was sie nicht tun
sollte wie zum beispiel nutzerdaten
ausgeben genau sowas darfst du dann mit
einem auftrag probieren muss man
natürlich sagen dass die fünf klassen
dann könnt ihr sagen
das ist spannend wie würde ich das jetzt
angehen also im endeffekt ist es
meistens so dass eine virtuelle maschine
und morpheus bringt mir alles bei ihr
findet den link zu seinen videos
übrigens in der video beschreibung alles
gerade vielen dank dann mache ich mich
jetzt mal die arbeit ich werde also
einen wlan passwort hecken zuallererst
brauche ich dafür ein anderes
betriebssystem denn auch weil man
theoretisch auch mit windows hecken
könnte ist linux bzw linux kali speziell
dafür ausgelegt mein leben als hacker
beginnt damit linux auf meinem laptop zu
installieren die mache ich das nie zu
gefühlt allem was mit informatik zu tun
hat hat zum aufbau auch dafür ein
tutorial und das befolge ich okay ich
bin jetzt drin ich habe eigentlich einen
windows laptop bin aber jetzt in diesem
fenster hier virtuell in einem
linux-betriebssystem drin und in diesem
betriebssystem gibt es hier diese ganzen
hacker funktionen keine ahnung passwort
text dass wir einfach alter ja schon
krass da sind einfach so richtig dreist
information gering passwörter tags
wireless ist schon heftig wie
offensichtlich das betriebssystem also
die version von linux aushecken
ausgelegt ist und wie geht man damit
jetzt ein passwort auch hier es ist
jetzt einfach 4 uhr 22 haben jetzt schon
den ganzen tag mich informiert alles
installiert alles aufgesetzt gehe habe
heute nicht schlafen bevor ich nicht
einen wlan direkt habe sage ich euch
unser wlan passwort ist jetzt geändert
am laptop wie ihr seht passwort ist
nicht drin nicht verbunden verbindung
hergestellt aber gehe natürlich nicht
ich will jetzt aber internet haben also
was mache ich hätte mich natürlich am
rhein ist ganz klar
grob gesagt funktioniert das so man
braucht einen wlan stick und
programmiert ihn darauf ständig auf ein
spezielles netzwerk zu wochen jetzt muss
ich nur noch jemand in das wlan
einloggen da so gut wie alle geräte und
handys ohnehin immer an und verbunden
sind kann das aber lange dauern der
wirklich geniale trick hier ist es einen
angriff zu starten der dafür sorgt dass
sich alle verbundenen geräte im ziel
wlan neu verifizieren müssen und genau
dort wo dieses passwort dann übermittelt
wird greift man es aus der luft denn
will dann fliegt er wortwörtlich durch
die luft da haben wir jetzt hier auch
links schon den wp handshake und das ist
ich brauche jetzt gehen der regel
passiert liste ok jetzt ziehen alle
zahlen durch das passwort ist jetzt auch
verschlüsselt und so setzt man ein tool
drauf an welches zwei meinem laptop zb
ganze 12.000 passwörter pro sekunde
ausprobiert so lange bis das richtige
gefunden wurde
jetzt fühle ich mich wie ein hacker also
ich glaube an der stelle ich jetzt auch
mal ins bett und lasst den kollegen mal
über nacht arbeiten obwohl gerade mit
12.000 passwörtern pro sekunde nach dem
richtigen gefahndet wird kann es stunden
tage und wochen dauern bis man ein
passwort knackt aber wie kann man
berechnen die sicher sein eigenes
passwort ist bei einem sechsstelligen
passwort bestehen aus kleinen buchstaben
wie zum beispiel tom r rechnet man ganz
einfach die zahl der in frage kommenden
ziffern also 26 hoch die anzahl der
ziffern also sechs herauskommen 308
millionen kombination das klingt jetzt
erst mal viel aber mit den 30.000
passwörtern pro sekunde die ein guter
desktop-pc schafft hat man in knapp
unter drei stunden alle kombinationen
und darunter auch die richtige das kommt
eher zufällig generierte passwort ein
abo für tommy ausrufezeichen hat zwei
groß und sieben kleinbuchstaben zahlen
und sonderzeichen dadurch gibt es 17
milliarden 374 millionen 411 milliarden
auf jeden fall ganz viele kombinationen
und um zu knacken würde das dauern
47.000 jahre
aber es gibt auch einen weg noch
deutlich schneller nach einem passwort
zu suchen dazu kommen wir später keynote
fand das ist eher traurig
warum ok ich ja was spannendes was viel
versprechen dass gefunden ich habe jetzt
quasi diese verschlüsselte dateien
nochmal bereinigt und probiert jetzt
aber noch einmal neu ok es probiert da
allemal durch jetzt iv primaria passwort
habe ich herausgefunden also schon
erzählen aber dass ein eigenes wlan zu
hacken ist natürlich ein bisschen
langweilig was jetzt richtig krass wird
wenn ich dass wir dann von dem komplex
aber natürlich habe ich seine erlaubnis
dafür sonst wäre das hier illegal
ich mache mich jetzt auf dem weg zum
tatort es ist ein unglaublich komisches
gefühl
er ist ständig heute erst dann wieder
ich habe es jetzt höre ich gerade ab
jetzt endlich das signal
ich hab nix
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die beute ist da alles was ich brauche
ist jetzt eine mini kleine datei auf
meinem laptop und wenn jetzt auch mein
pc gebracht und dann an meinem pc
geknackt weil der hat umgekehrt jemand
so viel power wie man laptops
[Musik]
die erste datei beinhaltet schon mal gar
nix die zweite datei die hat auch nix
dritter teil hat auch die letzte da war
als letzter zeit an und hier so
anstrengend ein herber rückschlag die
stundenlange arbeit und der durch die
ganzen passanten enormen stress dem ich
als hacker vor sebastians haustür
ausgesetzt waren umsonst aber ich gebe
nicht auf und sie die ganze nacht durch
um mir wissen anzueignen über
netzwerksicherheit aber auch über
sicherheitslücken in windows rechnern
zeit spielt keine rolle ich möchte
sebastians wlan-netzwerk nacken komme
was da wolle
draußen ist schon wieder absolut helle
ist 16 uhr 20 ich gehe jetzt lass mich
an wird sie komplett durchgezogen habe
alles gelesen was ich brauche um heute
auf jeden fall oder morgen auf jeden
fall in einem windows-pc passwort zu
knacken was schon mal richtig heftig
wird und ich habe mich auch noch ein
bisschen weiter gebildet was das wlan
passwort angeht damit wir da heute auf
jeden fall erfolgreich sind
gute nacht nach einer runde erholsamen
schlaf versuche ich erneut das passwort
von meinem kumpel zu hacken
okay let's go geht es vor der maschine
hier unser wlan adapter denn die jekyll
hinter der wähler darauf dass jetzt zum
hacken ausgelegt und jetzt gehts los auf
dem linken fenster da jetzt vielleicht
überwachung die luft und auf dem rechten
fenster startet jetzt das herauspicken
es gibt auch mit da ist ein handshake
ich bin tatsächlich drin jetzt ne ja ich
müsste jetzt noch merken ich bin ich bin
noch nicht aber ich habe die datei jetzt
und jetzt stelle ich mich damit nach
hause
ein passwort ist also alles was jetzt
kommt ist tatsächlich ziemlich leicht
ich ziehe mir einfach die daten von
diesem usb stick auf meinem pc damit ich
die da viel schneller cracken kann jetzt
greifen einfach diese datei ab die ich
bei dem wasser und aus der luft
gegriffen hat mit einem passwort mit
dieser wortliste ab die mehrere gigabyte
groß und einer parade kombination von
buchstaben drin hat lst und jetzt muss
ich nur noch einzudrücken
und jetzt gleich da alle kombinationen
ab ich denke das dauert mein pc hat
jetzt mit knapp 30.000 pro sekunde
dadurch das geht jetzt auf über vier
stunden hier hoch und ihr seht auch
gerade das meine cpu zu 100 prozent
ausgelastet ist
16 kinder gehen auf hochtouren mein
prozessor wartet jetzt gerade mit 26.000
haus werden pro sekunde durch und ich
versuche jetzt mal herauszufinden wie
schnell meine grafikkarte das hinkriegt
also wenn ich mich jetzt nicht wie so
oft täusche sollte das jetzt
funktionieren jetzt passiert was okay es
funktioniert und es ist übertrieben
schnell es geht einfach mit 425.000
passwörtern pro sekunde jetzt durch alle
kombinationen durch und es dauert jetzt
nur noch 20 minuten
und dann haben wir das passwort da ist
das passwort abe creepy hat 13 minuten
gedauert mit meiner grafikkarte jetzt
ich gehe jetzt mal rüber zu sebastian
und können wir kostenloses wlan let's go
einstellungen passt hbp haben kurz
gucken ob das funktioniert hier auf
youtube gegen das eher langsames
internet aber es geht ja drin also ich
meine klar dass pastor war leicht ist
beim nach dem ersten versuch entwickelt
ist dass ich einfach nicht drauf aber
ich bin profi
ich habe auch erst vor kurzem
mitgekriegt dass mercedes benz einfach
gehackt wurde und scheinbar hat der
mercedes-benz social media kanal einfach
ein vierstelliges passwort gehabt und
das ist einfach nur blöd also da muss
man echt aufpassen und gerade auch zwei
faktor verifikation reinmachen da hat
man keine chance
erstaunt ich könnte euch ein sicheres
passwort alles was jetzt noch fehlt ist
es einen windows pc zu knacken und auch
wenn ich erst einige stunden gebraucht
habe bis ich den dreh raus hatte es geht
wirklich simpel
also meine freundin hat jetzt das
passwort geändert und ich habe keinen
plan aber das ist auch egal und zwar
deswegen was viele nicht wissen ist dass
man bei windows pcs ganz normal im
anmelde fenster diese kommandozeile
öffnen kann aber leider hat die nicht
alle rechte also installiere ich auf
einem usb-stick das betriebssystem linux
ubuntu und staat in meinem pc nicht über
windows sondern über diesen usb stick
dann kann ich einfach diese bilder
kommandozeile durch die op admin
kommandozeile austauschen indem ich sie
einfach umbenennen und nun kann ich mit
dieser kommandozeile ganz einfach das
passwort beliebig ändern ohne das alte
zu kennen und und ich bin drin
man muss zugeben sebastian hat es mit
einem
nur acht stellen passwort schon echt
leicht gemacht und wenn da nur eine zahl
und einem sondertraining gewissen wir
jetzt direkt tage gedauert das zu
knacken man muss auch sagen dass das was
ich gemacht wird keine große kunst sein
vergleich zu anderen sachen aber ich
sind halt trotzdem klar ist wie viel ich
jetzt innerhalb von vier tagen gelernt
habe und theoretisch anrichten könnte
aber ist natürlich nicht tun werde
erstens weil hecken illegal ist deswegen
natürlich auch schon ultra viele leute
hinter gitter sitzen und zwar ins auch
weil es absolut uncool ist und es ist
auch echt ein bisschen kompliziert also
es wird glaube ich nicht mein neues
hobby wie ihr sehen könnt gibt es im
internet dutzende videos mit denen
einfach jeder hecken werden kann und die
hat auch gesehen wie viel sicherer
ein langes und kompliziertes passwort
ist aber wer kann sich so was schon
merken niemand aber das ist auch kein
problem mit dem sponsor des heutigen
videos der schweren ist eine app für
handy und pc die nicht nur eure
passwörter sicher verwahrt sondern diese
auch automatisch bei websites für euch
zum login ein trägt zusätzlich dabei ist
sogar ein vpn mit dem man von
verschiedenen ländern auf das internet
zugreifen kann ohne sich dabei verfolgt
zu fühlen klick auf den link in der
video beschreibung und erhalt der
stellen auf dem ersten gerät kostenlos
und die ersten 100 von euch erhalten 25
prozent rabatt auf den premium service
mit dem coach connery im nächsten video
versuche ich innerhalb von einer woche
einen song zu produzieren und in einer
sportart zu kriegen wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchte abonniert gerne diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir zum nächsten
mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]